and I think those four months there were
times in there where I remember speaking
to my family be like what have I done
I've left such a good business to do
something that look good but is really
tough and I don't know if I can do this
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host heus and on this week's episode I
was joined by Daniel B who's worked in
the recruitment industry for just over
six years and for the last 2 years he's
been building his own recruitment
business called jlb you've been on a you
know not the the typical journey in the
sense of work in you know one
recruitment agency or have many
recruitment agencies for 5 years 6 years
seven years you got exposure to pnls
managing people and then you started
your own business Dan was done with
recruitment he was ready to tap out
after working for a business for over
four years he thought he'd had enough
but then he met the right partner and he
started his own recruitment business
recruiting in an industry he's never
recruited in before the sports industry
so what I really respect about this is
that Dan has built his business entirely
from scratch and we really talk about
how he's navigated that journey in these
last two years there's so much to take
away from this conversation for anyone
that is building a market from scratch
is building a business from the ground
up what have been some of the the Steep
learning curves there that you've really
had to get your head around or anything
you found difficult on that side the
hardest bit about recruitment in my
opinion enjoy this week's episode Dan
welcome to the podcast thanks for having
me thanks for for coming and obviously I
said to you that um intended on on
getting you on but you've been subbed in
mate thank you thanks privilege yeah I'm
I'm really looking forward to unpacking
the this last two years I think as we
were just saying like you've been on a
you know not the the the typical journey
in the sense of worked in you know one
recruitment agency or have many
recruitment agencies for 5 years six
years seven years you got exposure to
pnls managing people and then you
started your own business um wasn't
quite the case for you so let's let's do
the the career highlights and let me
know if I get any of this wrong sure but
you entered the recruitment in
2017 uh your world was support staff for
alternate investment firms yeah um so
your first year was was entirely focused
on being a candidate resourcer sure
right um then second year it was very
much now you were doing BD bringing your
own clients all of that um and then you
stayed there for another two years and
even um helped them open up their New
York office but then over the last two
years you were you actually thought
about leaving the recruitment industry
was not sure if it was for you uh we'll
get into it but obviously you really you
just felt like what you shared with me
that you wanted to get into the sports
industry right you're going to have to
share with me like why you was so
compelled to do that um and anyway you
then thought why don't I start a sports
recruitment business and this is where
we are so you started uh jlb in February
yeah February 2021 2021 y you're uh
obviously yeah had the first year second
year sorry October October sorry yeah so
so first year second year and this is
what we're going to talk about the last
like two years J that you've been on um
so first year uh again if I'm wrong here
I think by the end of the year you had
around three people y eight months of
that were the first year was just you
yep um and you did just under 300 Grand
in the first year second year today
you're on around 500 500k currently your
goal 700 and currently there's um seven
people including you and then you're
hoping to be around a team of 10 people
by the end of the the second year right
and you're your world is the sports
industry yes um and I think all all you
do is uh it's all perm recruitment right
yep and then you also do not just the UK
done us stuff y also UAE as well right
exactly yeah here we are so okay okay
let's um let's first start with like
what what stand's perspective on the
common characteristics and traits that
make up a highly successful recruit in
today's market let's start there sure so
I feel like I've listened to a lot of
the answers to this um to narrow it down
to one I think it needs to be someone
that's not afraid of challenging and
what I mean by that is challenging the
internal team clients candidates on what
good looks like because I think it's so
easy for recruiters to come into a
market and just do what everybody else
does because it works but actually the
ones that challenge their clients on
what good looks like how recruitment
should be done I think those become the
Future Leaders and they um they're
increasing the perception of what
recruitment looks like so a Challenger
um it's hard to be a challenger at the
start because you're learning and it's
all new But as time progresses I I
always like it when the new highs come
and say why aren't we doing this or we
could be doing that better so a
challenger I think I love that that's
really cool I think that's yeah I
couldn't agree more I I really like
that so
jlb should we just also just um if it's
okay with you I know obviously um it's
it's part of the journey right but
obviously worth noting that you started
this business as um with Jackson l
help right so so they helped in the
sense of like back office like business
stuff so Dan could focus on selling
definitely let's just talk about so you
shared with me it
took uh didn't build until January so
what October November December four
months right four months yeah so what
was like where I'd love to start was
like compelled to being in a sport then
I'm assuming you thought well well you
can tell me like where when did you then
arrive actually why don't I combine my
you know really real interest in sport
with my skill set that I've built over
the last four
years so to give you a bit of context
when I was um I just finished my time at
JW search and wanted to to leave
recruitment to be honest I was a bit fed
up I tried to launch a new office um
during covid and just got um frustrated
by H how how tough the job was but also
mentally it just drained me so I thought
right let's work an industry that I
really love and I've always played sport
I've always loved sport and I thought
right okay I'm going to look at jobs in
sport what I soon realized is that I'd
probably have to take sort of a 70% pay
cut just to get in and uh I don't if my
ego's too big I just wasn't willing to
do it so I thought as a midpoint as a
mid-ground why don't I create a
recruitment firm in the sports industry
and I didn't really see many people that
were doing it there was a few people
that doing it well a few people that
doing it executive Search level but I
thought actually there's something here
so um I got introduced to Jackson by by
someone who used to work there who used
to be in Recruitment and spoke with Nile
and James who are the partners there and
they said right okay what's the plan
what's the business plan I said right
okay this is my idea wouldn't it be cool
and they said yeah would it be cool but
does it make any money so I had to put a
business plan together pitch them pitch
me to them really because most business
plans on the first day they go out the
window and if I look back to my initial
business business plan I'd probably
think God that's some awful ideas the
numbers are so off there you know what
am I doing so um anyway they they
believed in me to to do that and we've
sort of forged away in the sports
industry um yeah now to a team of eight
just about to hire our ninth person to
launch the US office so um things are
going in the right direction there's
clearly a need for it a market there um
but I went into it blind I didn't really
go into didn't know anyone in the
industry like no like candidate like all
that cuz that's the typical story so I
think it's so which I really commend
because most people that was just
interviewing someone that worked um has
a cyber security recruitment business
before they started their business they
worked in that industry for three and a
half years right so you have covenants
but then after the covenants you can
then of course tap into all those
relationships you didn't have that no no
and I also had zero BD experience and
that might sound ridiculous yeah after
four years because I was in such a great
uh machine J search where they've got
such a good reputation in the market and
a lot of our clients just came to us you
know through referral so I was given
things on on day one and maybe we'll
into sort my first year as a biller but
um I didn't know how good I had it and
then I went into the wild west of what
recruitment actually is and how hard it
is to bring on clients and I had to
learn the hardware and I think those
four months there were times in there
where I remember speaking to my family
be like what have I done I've left such
a good business to do something that
looked good but is really tough and I
don't know if I can do this and um I
think two years in I'm still thinking
right have I got it but there's clearly
something there and I think it's now
just about um keep going so let let's
talk about those first couple of months
then sorry to bring you back to a perod
which was obviously uh challenging but
like talk just talk us through like what
did those ear you know early you know
three four five six seven eight weeks
like what day today what did it look
like what was you doing what was you
running into like what did those first
couple of weeks where you started to
have those like oh my God like great
idea you know sounded great when I
started I had this business plan but I'm
just I'm not I don't feel like I'm you
know getting interaction I don't know
how you felt but like what what did that
actually look like what were you doing
in those couple of weeks sure so um look
no one knew who I was in sport and I had
no connection so the first thing I
thought of doing is just try and meet
people just try and get in front of
people and ask for their advice because
people love giving advice you know play
into someone's ego play into someone's
experience and say look this is what I'm
doing this is the journey that I'm on
can you be part of it and some people
bought in some people said no so I just
got in front of as many people as
possible
and asked them about how they had got
jobs in sport before and just used that
time as like okay I need to figure out
how this all works and what sport
actually is because I thought I knew
what sport was I had no idea so uh I had
to learn from people that had worked in
the industry and eventually uh someone
gave me a shot and said look I like what
you're doing um I've dealt with some
pretty Rogue recruiters before I'll give
you a shot for two weeks and I managed
to fill that job eventually um but it
took me four months to get it before um
I was 2 months in and I had one client
where I got three offers I got got
someone to final declined someone to
final declined someone declined and I
thought at that point I was like I don't
know if I can do this this might not be
for me um I just had so much doubt
because I'd come from billing quite good
quite well um and then I was just like I
can't do this I'm rubbish I'm so rubbish
at this job but anyway four months in I
was like okay I've done a I've done a
role I've I've filled I filled a job and
the the momentum picked up and then so
let let's just break that down a bit
yeah what so I I I love that approach
what did that actually look like so are
you connecting with people on LinkedIn y
you're sending them a message sending
people an email saying like hey you
don't know me my name's Dan I'm building
this Sports recruitment business I'm
looking for some advice on you know like
how people enter the industry like what
did that actually sound like when you're
reaching out to people definitely so I
tried to meet three three to five people
a day if I could at the start um and it
was as simple as that people in sport
were really nice um so I it was more
like I'm trying to do something
different in sport I'm trying to
redefine what good looks like in
Recruitment and I'd love you to be part
of that story and and and sort of give
me some advice and practical advice I
wasn't asking for a job I wasn't asking
for an intro um you get a lot of nose as
I said but I just was really consistent
with it and as soon as I got in front of
someone I knew I could convince them to
keep them in in the front of mine and
essentially come back to me if the
opportunity came up so so when you then
spoke to someone yeah and they said oh
Dan look happy to help like I think
that's great great what you're doing
what was what did those calls sound like
then what was you like what was the
purpose of them how did you approach
them because you were saying you just
said like you knew that as soon as you
got in front of them but like what what
was you doing on those calls were you
saying like you know telling them a bit
about your story saying what you're
trying to build like how did you
approach those calls yeah I I told them
about my recruitment experience and and
that might not sounded like the the most
fun topic but I told them that I was
going to go to New York I was going to
going to live out there came back had to
come back CU of Co um and I wanted to do
something I was really really passionate
about so I just ran them through like
what I typically do as a recruiter
because a lot of sports organizations
have never use recruiters before they
just post an advert or they use their
own network so I had to educate a lot of
people on what we do like why you know
it's not just like we find someone and
send a big invoice to it's like okay
what actually goes into it or how much
time goes into it um and also played
into a little bit of the sports industry
isn't very diverse you know if you look
at the senior leadership teams of lot of
the big um rights holders and agencies
in London um people have just typically
moved from agency to agency or rights
holder to rights holder so my big thing
at Jos search or the big thing across
the agency was to Champion the hidden
Heroes and I love that and I thought why
don't we bring something like that into
sport where we're trying to Champion
people that would be great for the
sports industry but haven't got an
experience maybe they've worked in a
tech company or in finance
and we can pivot them into Sport and
they can make a difference so um a lot
of that was just sort of getting them to
buy into my methodology and what I think
about recruitment how I'm going to
challenge the wild card and be a
champion for them as well because there
is always a time when someone you know
turn goes on a Sunday and they're having
Sunday Monday blues and they're like
okay let's see what's out there let's
give Danner ring and that's what sort of
questions are you asking them then cuz
obviously you was also there to learn
about how things work so what what
things were you really trying to
understand so so understand how they'd
got jobs previously if they'd used a
recruiter what they' done well and what
they hadn't done so well I think there's
a lot of in recruitment there's a lot of
we're better than you we're better than
you but actually I think there's a lot
of recruiters that are good especially
in sport that do things really really
well and I want to know what they do
well because ultimately if they're good
giving a good service to their clients
we want to give the same to us so yeah
ask ask what they'd liked ask what they
didn't like ask about the value in in
recruitment do they see any value in it
um a lot of people said yes um which is
obviously why I sort of kept going um
and yeah ju just was really honest with
him and said look I I haven't got much
to offer you now um but it's funny two
years later I now have and and I've kept
those relationships and I'm I'm really
interested in people and their stories
and everyone's got a reason to um every
everyone's got a reason in sport to sort
of brush you to the side because they
get so many messages these people get so
many messages all the time but um I got
in in front of a few people and they
said yes and then they told their
friends and I met them so um okay yeah
it's grown quite organically but it was
really tough at the start like really
really tough was you like quite specific
with who you targeted was you targeting
people to speak to like having in mind
that these people might be hiring
managers or was you like just very open
on like who you would speak to was you
targeted there or I tried to meet people
that had had at least three jobs in
sports so I knew if they'd had three
jobs um they've got kind of a good um
opinion of of the sports industry and
have made maybe been in touch with a few
recruiters I didn't I didn't just go for
hiring managers or HR people I did meet
with a few HR people because I was
interested in you know when they use
recruiters what do they like what rates
they work at um I nearly fell off my
chair when I started to understand um
what sports a uh Sports organization
typically pay recruiters you know it's
typically around 10 to 15% and I'd come
from an agency where you know really
won't work anything below 25 so I was
like okay so I've got no network no
clients and the fees are really low and
I was like what have I done here um but
that I always believe that if you're
paying someone 15% you're getting a 15%
service if you're paying something
somebody 25% you're given a 25% service
and that's how I pitch to our clients
it's like okay you can pay someone 15%
to send you CVS or you can look at us
pay us a little bit more but get a lot
more back um okay so yeah it was it was
so what and then because I think this is
super interesting and people can apply
this to that you know you'll hear people
in recruitment talk about building a
market from scratch and these things and
you built a business and a market from
scratch yeah and in the thck of it now
still so this is why I think this be
helpful people and then final thing on
that like how did you then like map this
out like cuz you said three PE three
people uh um people that have had free
jobs in sport like did you just do like
a proper solid like Boolean search and
then just like I don't know how did you
approach that so at the start day one I
think I just was like I'm going to go
off after all the Premier League teams
today I'm going to go off yeah yeah yeah
I'm go after a big industry oh it's huge
it's huge and um I actually remember my
one of my second day I got a nibble off
um a marketing manager at Premiership
football club I won't I won't say their
name and they were like yep we're
looking to see more CVS and I turn
around to Nile and I was like oh my god
I've got a roll on there's a roll at
Premiership football club I'm going to
fill it uh didn't end up filling it
because look they they probably just say
that to most people and um I got lucky
but um look I what what I tried to do
with sports I I looked at um sports
teams and leagues in the UK to begin
with um Sports agencies Sports Marketing
agencies PR agencies right list and list
and list and then the last side I looked
at is Big brands that have a presence in
sport like Google and McDonald's and I
know they're big big companies but they
all have division Sports people exactly
so um I tried to have a real variety the
type of people that I would meet because
they'd see it from different angles but
um yeah I I would map it completely out
have like like a hundred of each in
those three divisions um and I just go
after 5 to 10 people at each each
business and just try and meet them and
then keep a record of who said yes who
said no follow up the people that said
No at the start then said yes so um and
then how long did it take you to have
that first op to potentially do your
first placement you said where it didn't
happen so that was within the first
month yeah so I I took on two or three
roles within my first month um just by
having that approach yeah just by having
that approach and and look I went met um
people in HR and I pitched myself and
that was really really tricky because it
happens all the time I mean there's so
many recruiters out there that want to
work in sport because it's glamorous
right it's no you're never going to
struggle getting enough candidates in
sport but um finding the best ones is
really really tricky what was the pitch
then what does that sound like cuz like
you said you haven't got a track record
yeah but you said to me that you really
lent into this is who I am this is what
I'm about this has been my recruitment
experience is what you you know when we
prepared for this what it sounded like
but what did those early meetings sound
like cuz I think that' be interesting
for people yeah so before I said um I
pitched myself and did the big sell I
always ask them what they're doing at
the moment because it's very hard to
sell yourself if you don't know where
the the challenges are I think it's very
easy sometimes to be like we're the best
we do this we do this but actually I
wanted to understand right where can I
help because there were conversations
where actually like everything's going
pretty well and our recruitment firm are
doing a good job and that's okay I
wasn't oh gutted I was kind of
interested what they doing well okay if
they weren't if they're not doing so
well what are you struggling with is it
time to hire is it the quality of the
candidates is the type of people you're
seeing a lot of people were saying
diversity not seeing very diverse
candidates and I and then my angle my
selling was that I've spent four and a
bit years championing people that don't
look great on paper but are great in the
job and here's an example of a few
placements that I did and although it
was in a completely different industry
they saw my passion for that that and
then when they bought into that they
were like okay let's have a let's have a
shot look you the beauty of what we do
sometimes is that you don't have to give
any money up front just let me show you
just let me show you so my the most
roing thing about what I have done in
recruitment or the placements that I've
made is when I've placed someone where
the hiring manager said no initially
those are my favorite recruitment
processes because that is the value we
can bring because I can send you five
clones of the brief that you've given me
and that's fine and you'll interview
them and there may be someone that
interviews well and you offer them a job
but then they get complement after 6 or
12 months and then they're looking again
whereas if you give someone opportunity
that's so hungry for it and is so Keen
to make an impression has got their
backup a little bit they will stay
longer and they will be a leader in that
business because they'll be forever
grateful that they got a shot so that's
the narrative that I tried to go down
and a few people believed in it so okay
so you so in the first month by having
that approach you were able to start
working on some jobs begin a short and
with that approach did you have to start
at 15%
yeah yeah cuz if that's what they being
us right I did but I think that that's
just good to share cuz you got to start
somewhere and I think which we'll get on
to I think as soon as you have those
like case studies like track record then
it it becomes a lot more easier right
and this is what you was working towards
like just being given a shot also for
yourself to be able to like prove to
yourself that you can bring that same
approach um and outcomes to this
industry that you've never done before
so first month and then but then you
weren't
successful that was tough you really
think about yeah I just was like can I
do this you know have I just been in
this bubble where like everyone succeeds
and it's such a good platform in my last
business that I was like okay I've come
out of the bubble and now it's like I've
start I've had to start again I've
almost think like I've been in
recruitment two years you know sometimes
that's how I think about it so when I
failed I was like okay why did I fail
what could I've have done differently
reviewed it and then I just had to go
again because my mentality when I when I
pitched jlb to begin with is that I will
not fail I refuse to fail I have that
mentality in probably all areas of my
life where I do I will not fail and um
that comes at a cost you know mentally
that is exhausting at times but I just
wasn't going to fail so got back up got
another job on worked it um and then it
was just before we went away for like
the Christmas break and um I remember
standing in the pouring rain in like
Oxford turus and the third offer had
been declined for this one job and I was
like just before Christmas yeah just
before Christmas I was like what's going
on like what's I I I can't do yeah can
BL it and he just got yeah I know I know
I know he just he just got a pay rise
before their January reviews and he was
like I can't it's not doesn't make any
sense to me so um I learned the hard way
but I always remember those times
because when things come to me now and
things are easy I don't take it for
granted and I try and I try and
Implement that to my team because um
when I've hired people into the business
they've often been hired in a time where
things are going really really well so
that's all they know um the the first
guy that hired Steph he came in at a
time where had loads of jobs on and it
was great and we were working with some
Premiership football clubs working with
some really interesting sports teams and
um and then all of a sudden it took a
dip and he was like what happens now I
was like well you got to get back on the
phone and you got to go meet people and
um it's it's good to to realize that
this is a really really tough job but
it's incredibly rewarding if you get it
right so then four months got your first
placement yeah and then so the first
placement was in was in January and then
in February I made two deals
then March made three and then I heard
someone and we made four and and to be
honest since then it's we haven't
blanked any there's no been no blanks
which has been great and we've always
build a minimum of about 15 grand and
and we just basically grown the team as
the numbers have gone up now I know
sometimes that's maybe not the best way
of doing things I hadn't come from I
hadn't had any experience in doing this
and to be honest I was given the freedom
to an extent to Dan if you're gut saying
we need to hire one more person let's
hire them um The Challenge we can maybe
come on to that but the challenge about
hiring everyone wants to work in sport
we' post a sports recruitment advert and
one of our adverts got 850 applications
850 applications so um there's no sort
of we didn't find it tricky to find good
people uh we just wanted to find people
that were in it for the right reasons
the wrong reasons were I just want to
tell my mates I work in sports sports
sounds really cool exactly the right
reasons are actually this industry needs
a big upgrade at this level um and I
want to make a difference so so let's
just talk about I want to go into like
down the business owner Journey CU I
think that' be really interesting but
just just just to sort of build on what
we've just been talking about which is
really painting a picture of what you
have to go through if you're building a
business a market from scratch and how
long it might take the knockbacks you
get along the way so you then like you
said from January then you continue to
build on that M so then from January
once you had that placement did you do
anything differently like what what did
your pitches and how did you then
approach things did you then really make
sure that you used that success that
you've done like how did you then
approach things from from that point
that meant just CU you get one placement
doesn't mean then it goes the direction
right so what what did you then change
or do differently do you think or what
you really leaning into that you think
gave you that opportunity to keep
growing each month sure so naturally
when you make um a deal your confidence
goes up so when I was on my next pitch
or when I got in front of someone else I
was like yeah we just did this and you
can obviously Leverage that but I just
think my mentality changed around right
let's not be negative here things are
still going to be tough but I've got one
person that I found a new job for and I
can leverage that and I can talk about
that story and talk about how I did it
so I think I wasn't doing anything
dramatically different I think just my
mentality in every phone call I just had
a bit of like a Swagger a bit of like I
can do this I can do this now and um I
can think bigger at the start I was just
like I've just got to place one job a
month right just get let's do 12 plac
this year that's what I thought point I
was and and I know that's really like um
that's not the the biggest goal in in
year one but I was like okay let's just
try and 12 find 12 people a job and then
I was like no let's think bigger than
that let's think way bigger than that
let's work with five key businesses in
sport and let's try and build out their
marketing teams that was my first first
thought um but look after my first
placement I just I just had so much more
belief in myself and I just gone s
through such a rocky road in the last 12
months where I went to New York had to
come back did it remotely fell out in
love with recruitment started a new
business from scratch had a lot of nose
and then one person was like yes we're
going to hire this person I was like
okay I I I was near I remember I was
like I was got quite emotional because I
was like this is this is so hard but I
can do it and then once I done one I was
like okay game on here I know what I'm
doing now um to an extent and uh and it
just sort of it flows from there so
what's been your most consistent
effective way of winning great clients
then cuz like you said you had limited
BD exposure like a lot became inbound
you'd spoken about I really love just
the approach of you know sharing people
uh your story and and getting time with
them and these things but then like yeah
what what's been like the mo like how
have you really approached that that's
that's worked for you
consistently uh keeping in touch with my
candidates keeping in touch with my
candidates is key and I've got people
that have come back to me in the last
month or so that I spoke to about a year
ago um but they've been following my
journey and they be following the team's
growth and now they're coming back to me
people that I've placed now are coming
back to me as well but um I didn't have
any tricks or tips at the F like I
remember making cold calls in my first
week and I remember like shaking and be
like what is going on here like this is
so outside of my comfort zone but for a
normal recruit that be like why is you
so well I was like oh my God what if
they say no I said what if they say no
what if they hang up the phone and then
um and then I realized like you're going
to get a lot of nose doing this and the
reason that I did I started JB is
because I knew there was something in me
that just wanted to um see if I could do
it see if I could run a business see if
I could build something from scratch and
um yeah it was it was really really
challenging but I just I think my my BD
tactics were just get in front of people
if I can get in front of someone I think
I can get them to buy into me and you
could call that overly confident or
arrogant but I just I I had to go into
that thinking that because if I didn't
then people would read that people think
oh this guy's not serious or um he's not
worth our time so I just went in and was
like this is who I am this is my story
you either like me or you don't and then
I'll meet someone else it's and you
really leverage your candid the
candidate Network and people that you've
spoke you've spoken to exactly exactly
and I told them about I had to educate
so many people on what recruitment is
you go into different Industries like
Finance Tech cyber and there's loads of
recruiters out there and people know
what recruiters do in
sport a lot of people don't know what
recruiters actually do because they've
just got jobs through their own network
or they've just applied to a LinkedIn
advert so um yeah a lot of that was not
just finding a new market being a
competition but telling people what
recruitment is and that's an extra layer
but if you can do that in a really
successful way then they're always going
to come back to you because you were the
ones that show showed them the value in
what you do um yeah this podcast is
proudly partnered with vin Cherry the
all-in-one recruitment agency software
that over 20,000 recruiters trust daily
we're also partnered with the
award-winning oneup sales sales and
motivation platform that Ables you to
maximize the potential of your teams we
love partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you
listening to this podcast and get up to
10% off the usage price forever use the
link in the show notes to get your hands
on that let's get back to the episode so
obviously we've spoken a lot about the
initial period would you do anything
differently now so if someone's listened
to this they're week one like you were
you know their hands are shaking they're
calling people might be a brand new
market or they they've got covenants
they can't call their old uh clients
like would you do anything different
than those first like 90
days it's a really good question um I
think I could have thought bigger right
I I at the start it was like as I said
Premiership Premier League football
teams right um I Sports a global a
global industry and there's so many
sports organizations out there and also
so maybe I wouldn't have gone for the
traditional sports teams and leagues
maybe I would have gone for some smaller
like sport tech companies or startups
that needed help um so yeah think bigger
and don't think mainstream at the start
um often the most mainstream Sports and
the mainstream teams often the trickiest
to work with um which I've learned the
hard way so um I I would have looked
bigger at the start that's probably the
main thing that I would have done but to
be honest I'm I'm pleased that I learned
the hard way you know I'm pleased I made
those mistakes I'm pleased I had those
times where I doubted it because it
means now I know I really want it so um
it's hindsight's a wonderful thing but I
don't think I would have done that much
differently just maybe think a little
bit bigger think bigger and then maybe
go to the like less obvious places yeah
whatever like Market your end you know I
mean exactly yeah so talk to me
about like you hadn't managed anyone
before no and now you're uh you know
responsible for the p&l what you're
spending yeah um and and now maning a
lot of people yeah you're responsible
for people's livelihoods yeah so talk to
me a bit about that like
what what have you found hard about that
that maybe you least
expected so I played I played a lot
rugby growing up and I was in a position
where I was a bit of a leader and I love
that part of my job right um but I'm
actually not the most extroverted guy I
actually love my own space and love
quiet time and I'm not there banging the
walls on a Monday morning saying right
let's make loads of deals that that is
my version of
um I don't say hell that's quite a
strong word but it's not me it's not me
right so um but I craved I craved giving
someone the exposure to recruitment that
had never been in it before because I
think it's just been it's been a
brilliant career path for me I had my
doubts at times I fell into it like
everyone else but it's given me so much
and I was I was craving that opportunity
to teach someone train someone and show
them how it can basically transform them
their lives in a in it sounds dramatic
but in a lot of ways it has done to me
so um I think yeah managing like seven
nearly eight people when when he starts
in October um I've had to prioritize my
own time more um but having not managed
anyone before I think it the good thing
was the way that we scaled is we hired
one person sort of eight months in then
I had two months with him before we
hired the next person so at each chapter
I could give a lot to one person and
then they'd become a little bit
self-sufficient and then i' give a lot
to the next person um but it it was
really really challenging and I had to
learn the balance between being
someone's friend and being their manager
and that's the trickest bit for me
because I think I've naturally got this
thing in me where I want everyone to
love me I want everyone to really like
me um but you can't do that in managing
I think yeah I'm going to ask you on
that cuz interviewed someone called Ole
who had to learn that yeah which was
like he really had to learn about um the
difference about being nice and being
kind yeah cuz you can be kind to someone
and being kind to someone and saying hey
Dan I'm not sure this is right for you
because of what you know about them that
that's being kind rather than just being
nice yeah so what so what is what's been
difficult about that like you don't want
to piss people off or you always want
that you like to just see the good in
people and the potential in people yeah
I I always uh I did a post about this
the other month and about the airport
test if you can sit uh in an airport
with someone for four and hours you
probably should hire them because you
can spend a lot of time with that person
so everyone that I've hired I've really
liked I've bought into their story I've
bought into their them as a person so
when it came to managing and especially
when you're small and part of something
that's new you want to be in the
trenches with them and you want to be
mates with them because you know that
you'll you'll sort of fight for each
other but um what my I think my strategy
was or with the people that I brought on
is teach them the fundamentals give them
the fundamental s of recruitment and
this job right um and give them metrics
or kpis to to go towards to to aim
towards but I am going to be there I'm
not always going to be there to hold
your hand because I want you to make
mistakes but I am there if you are
finding this really really challenging
and also like a lot of my management
time is speaking to people about like if
they're mentally struggling or things
that are going on outside of work I
really want to buy into that I think a
lot of managers maybe the perception is
that 9 till six they're there from six
onwards they're not and I think
sometimes my um
my priest achievement is just being
being there for my team when it's not
about recruitment when they've had
really tough moments in their personal
lives that is mentally draining for me
but it's the sacrifice that I've chosen
to make um to build to build a business
so um I had no management experience I
now manage seven nearly eight people um
I've learned a lot of tough lessons
along the way I will continue to learn a
lot of tough lessons but it showed me
that that's a part of the job I love I
really really love managing people and
being that that person that they can go
to when they need help um it's yeah not
an easy
job and then what have been some of your
steepest learning CES on like the
business side or is that something that
the the partner with the guys have
really helped with but like what what's
been cuz often you tell me but I think
sometimes the the perception of you know
starting your own business what often
people can be really uh F really
daunting is like I've never uh had
access to or had to understand what a
p&l is or
you know what revenue is to GP is or you
know setting up my uh terms and getting
all that or getting paid on time like
what what have been some of the the
Steep learning curves there that you've
really had to get your head around or
anything that you found difficult on
that side the hardest bit about
recruitment in my opinion is getting the
money in the bank uh sounds getting paid
so hard
um yeah or do they help with that they
do help with that um but ultimately if
it's your client you've got the
relationship should be on you I think a
lot of the time I think a lot of people
underestimate this did you underestimate
that you don't think about that you
thought about that Jo search would you
big time J search I make um number of
place do a deal make a placement get
paid the following month you know they
had a lot of cash flow there and we just
got paid out um when it was due to like
a month after we' made a placement right
but as typically in recruitment you get
paid when your client play pays you so
that was really really challenging um
and it's challenging for my my team as
well because they're they're young
people they do something really really
good and they've got to wait two or
three months to get paid Dan like that's
not our payment terms 30 days I was like
I know it's 30 days I think my first
placement was pretty good but we've had
I've had like seven eight grand fees
where it's taken the client eight months
to pay eight months yeah eight months
and we've never wor with yeah we've
never worked with them again but eight
eight months to chase a fee [__] and I'd
come from I'd come from a business where
you know private Equity hedge funds they
pay on time you deliver a service they
pay um sport is a little bit different
so um I think that comes down to maybe
that initial call that initial call with
them when we're so how do you approach
it now because I was literally texting
someone like the other week about how
you're going on they start their
business she was like I'm still I'm
waiting for these [__] retainers to
be paid like cuz this is something that
people underestimate so like you've had
to learn that the hard way which I
appreciate you sharing like how do you
try and there's only certain things you
can control right like if you deliver a
service and you've said everything that
you normally say and then you send the
invoice and I take [__] ages to pay
it yeah that's quite hard but like how
do you try and influ how do you try and
mitigate that now then how you just said
there on like um how you approach it but
like how do you actually approach that
now to give you the best chance of being
paid on time so I talk about it a lot on
my first call with a client um
especially when take on a brief and just
to say like just to at the end well not
not at the end of actually prioritize it
and say look these are our payment terms
um are we set up on your system have we
signed all the forms have we done all
that because that's another thing that
gets delayed you know you make a
placement and it's coming up oh just
checking in we're going to get paid
tomorrow oh you haven't filled out these
forms that's another two weeks so um I
try and address all of that on the first
call and not be shy about it people
sometimes don't want to talk about money
you know it's like a dirty word right um
but I I try and address that on the
first call and say look these are our
payment terms this is what we expect I'd
love it if we got a card or like a you
know a down down payment that'd be great
but um it often we have to trust that
they will live up to that I think if you
build a really good relationship with a
client and um after you've made a deal
it's not just okay when are we going
going to get paid if it's more
consultative than that you go in and
meet them again and say right let's do a
review how did we do and then at the end
of the meet to go just to make sure
we're we're all set to get paid in two
weeks time three weeks time don't be
afraid to talk about it um so you said
at the very beginning talk about your
payment terms yeah have you changed your
payment terms to 30 days to 14 days I
have in some situations what I've done a
lot more recently as my confidence
continues to grow is we've got half the
fee up front with 14-day payment terms
and clients have been really on board
with that because we're so we're then so
committed to filling that role there's
no chance that we're not going to fill
it so I'm I'm now trying to move our
team I don't want to call it retained
model it's just something up front it's
a buy in you know even if a client gives
you 100 quid they're probably going to
answer the phone more than they would
they're probably going to give you
feedback on the CVS they're going to be
bought in to who you are because they've
paid you a bit of money so I'm trying to
get half upfront now I'm trying to push
that across the whole team because you
know what it's like in contingent
recruitment you you you run around um
run around the races and then you you
get a no at the end like I done all that
work and I've got nothing back so um I
talk about it I'm really open with our
clients and say look it comes at a cost
to use us and I think sometimes they
like that they like that you value your
service so so what's been like how long
on average of you it's taken you to get
paid then most of our clients pay in 30
days i' probably say there was 30% of
the fees so in two years we've made
about 100 placements right and I would
say 30 of those have been a nightmare 30
of those have been nightmare Chase was
that quite early on as well would you
say yeah some of it some of it was early
on I think as we've grown it's funny
when you make when it's repeat business
and you make you're setup and it's
really clean but with new clients which
a lot of the time it has been um it has
been challenging and I've Le I learned
the hard way and you cannot sit next to
someone and B say press this button I
need to get my money it's really tough
it's really really tough and I don't see
a lot of um recruitment uh owners or
people talk about that but obviously if
you're in a bigger recruitment firm you
don't have to worry about that have to
worry about that how how so did you drw
that into your team now you like do also
get them to talk about on the on
remember when you I don't know about you
but when you like as employeed
negotiating terms all you're thinking
about is the percentage of course that's
all you're thinking about I'm I'm not
and maybe like the rebate period yeah
but besides that I'm not thinking about
[__] when we get paid I'm just like
yeah it's 25% that's what we work to and
I'm just thinking about how can I get
them to agree to the highest percentage
um not thinking about and this is our
payment terms yeah so do you have you
got your team to understand the
situation the percentage nothing if the
money's not in the bank you know you
know 15% in the bank is better than 25%
not in the bank and it sounds silly to
say that but it's it's so true in
recruitment so um not being afraid to
have those conversations with our I love
that and then have you and then Have you
communicated that does that affect when
you pay people's commission yeah it does
it does because we pay people out we
have a cut off about the 18th or the
19th every month and if the client pays
before that then it will go into that
month's paycheck but that will be from
the month before you made that clear to
the team yeah they know that they know
know that um we've had a few people that
have learned the hard way and it's
really tricky to have those
conversations but it all comes down to
what could we have done on that first
call to make it crystal clear that um
these are our payment terms now another
thing that we do which I know is not
maybe traditional for contingent
recruitment but I think has been really
successful for us is we invoice our
clients on the day that the candidate
signs the employment contract so we have
a lot of candidates more at the senior
level that the um on three month notice
so say it takes a month to do the
recruitment process they then hand in a
notice it's then that's four months
until they start there's then another 30
days on top it's five months it could be
half a year it could be six months until
one of my team gets paid and and then
you can't run a business on that and if
I had like when I have those
conversations with my clients say look
we're a small business we can't we have
we can't do that in terms of cash flow
we cannot afford to get paid in six
months time so what we do do with our
clients is between signing the contract
and St stting if they if they failed to
start for whatever reason we'll give
them the money back hasn't happened
hasn't happened in aund placements
hasn't happened because don't if it's
sport or it's our process but people are
so bought into their next role so
committed they'll work their notice and
they they won't drop out because
opportunities in sport don't come about
all the time so they know that they've
got something good here they can't just
like keep looking while they're working
their notice they have to take the role
they've committed to so yeah so you send
the invoice when they sign a contract
yes sign a contract resign agree a start
date there been a lot of push back on
that then or has it been fairly was a
start but now now it's it's common
practice and that's the way that we
operate that's a good tip for people
yeah did you talk about that at the
beginning as well say like this payment
terms we invoice when the person signed
the contract guess you can share the
story that of course if they don't start
for whatever reason you'll get you know
your entire money back no questions
asked however that hasn't happened yet
um and then you explained the because
the because of the reason um of like it
could be six months if we waited until
they started exactly when I when I tell
clients that they go oh okay that makes
sense you know if you were in my shoes
you'd probably want the same so they get
it they get it and I think having that
insurance of how getting the money back
is is key yeah I think that's a really
good tip uh for people so how have you
how have you then in line with that like
how have you managed cuz you have like
you said you've you have hire people
quite quickly y I feel
like with that Journey right so are you
like how are you how have you approached
like have you thought about you know how
much uh Revenue um you're generating
before you decide to hire someone have
you have you tried to grow into that or
are you like quite happy now with the
amount of people you're going to have
and you're just going to focus on
maximizing you know all the people that
you have obviously I don't know exactly
how it works partnership you have I'm
assuming maybe you have a bit more
support in the financial Runway I don't
know but like in terms of it seems like
you might have had had people that might
um might not be profitable y so yeah to
be clear we wouldn't have grown this
quickly if it was just me if just my
money I don't think that would be um the
right right way of doing things but what
we what we've tried to do is we' we've
been aggressive in terms of growth plans
and I know to get up to nearly 10 people
in two years is is ridiculous for some
people but what we've tried to do is um
as we've grown as we've made more deals
we've identified the areas of sport that
needs servicing and then we've hired
people to do those areas so now our team
is separated it's not at the start it
was just Dan wi's clients Dan brings the
roles on we'll all just do everything we
can to fill it and we just grow G gr gr
there's only so far you can do doing
that so we've now separated the sports
industry specifically into different
areas where people focus and they focus
their BD efforts they focus their
candidate conversations they're building
a market in the same way that I did at
the start so for example we got someone
that focusing on on um hospitality and
events within Sport and you might be
thinking well that's not really sport
but it is you know if they're working
for a sport organization with a head of
operations or a head of events role for
us that that is that's good we love that
so we've got people who do that we've
got people that focus on Sports
technology we've got a guy that's doing
just Dubai in UAE at the moment uh we've
got people that are just doing Sports
Marketing firms I typically work with a
lot of our rights holders teams leagues
the more traditional Sports
organizations and then obviously we've
got a team now that um operat in the US
and I think one thing I haven't
mentioned is that the Jackson l group um
which is made up of three businesses has
got an office in Austin so we have used
the Austin office and their resources
for some of the searches we brought on
which again is great leverage in that
initial call being like okay we are in
London now but we've got a satellite
team in Austin and I think people have
really really like that um so with the
when you get to 9 10 people you're going
to be quite are you going to be quite
happy with all the different niches that
they have I think so I think so for now
um and also I'm conscious of my time as
well it's very hard for me to manage
nine people but
ultimately my goal is to in a year's
time probably only manage two or three
you know directly because they'll have a
team and they'll have built a division
themselves so at the moment it's very
intense um everyone's sort of at the
beginning of their recruitment Journey
they're learning the hard way in a new
market remember I've hired nobody from a
sports recruitment firm that had an
existing Network so I I made it really
really challenging for myself but I knew
the long game was that right we're going
to build something here that's different
they're going to learn how to do
recruitment properly and in the future
in you know two three years time it's
going to pay dividends so
um yeah that's the goal how how's the
how's the approach on the US how's that
going yes it's it's going well I mean
we've of the 100 placements we've
probably so 30% I would say has come
from the US side the the most successful
way that we've got into the US market is
by speaking to our our London clients or
UK businesses and getting introductions
there um everyone's in the US Market I
mean I feel like I see so much stuff
about you higher fees etc etc I get it I
get it but in the sports industry a lot
of the um recruitment that's done is
only done at the executive Search level
so still at like the mid to senior and
the more Junior roles they're still done
through advertisement internal t a lot
people want to get into everyone wants
to work in sport oh my God everyone
wants to work in sport I did a post this
week about the average amount of
applications we get on our jobs because
we post all our jobs um what is the
average amount 385 applications per job
and like is there good quality people in
there really good quality people really
really good PE really really good people
so but it takes a lot of time to sift
through so you know in internal ta teams
will have all these applications come to
them directly uh have to sift through by
the time they've got to a second or
third state interview they've dropped
out or they've gone in another process
so um that's our value I mean I don't
have to say every recruiter says that
about sort of internal ta versus using
an agency but um in sport it is
magnified because everyone everyone sees
a job advert for a marketing manager at
a Premiership football club and they
press apply cleaners dog walkers
everyone's applying so um yeah our our
value is is now and down making it a bit
more simple so what's been really
effective is getting referrals from UK
customers yes into the US yeah and then
you've really had to just identify the
maybe hard to fill roles which can't be
e e easily done by you know doing the
job adverts and all those things yeah we
we work with a really well-known Sports
marketing agency in l
that wanted to hire their first person
in New York and I was like yes I will do
this and I did it in 3 weeks and um and
I was like okay we've got something here
so now the reason we' brought someone in
is because I know there's a market there
hu huge opportunity but I can't do
everything so I think I'm probably going
to spending more more of my time on the
US market as we go on um but um we can
do it there's there's no reason why we
can't and um I think the US is probably
where we're going to shift more more of
our business too in the next year or so
so what what are you really remaining
laser focus on now then like what what's
really top of mind for you then top of
mind is to still give clients an amazing
experience I think when you grow a team
and you give people a few roles and you
you start handing them out your worry is
that the quality it won't be as good as
if I did it right or if it's not I
haven't trained them as well as I could
have so always to Quality is is top of
top of bind all the time in especially
when it comes to client experiences
because they've got so many other
recruiters that they could just go to if
you don't do very very well and the
sports industry especially in the UK is
very very insular so people talk if you
have a bad exper I always you know I was
always tall um in recruitment if you
give someone a good experience they tell
five people if you give someone a bad
experience they tell 10 and I tell my
team that because they need to know that
if they mess up or if they don't give a
client the best of experiences then they
may not come back to you and that's a
relationship ruined and that's a client
that then talks to a few people and and
so what have been some of the things
recently that you've implemented in your
processes that you think has you know
improved the The Experience out of
Interest so traditionally we take a
brief and then within 48 hours we'll
send CVS so what we've now started to do
is um say right we're going to send CVS
in four days let's say but in two days
time we're going to have a a call to do
some calibration so we're going to say
right these are the people that we're
thinking of presenting these are the
best people that we've got and we think
are right for this role what do you
think give us some instant feedback
because it's so often that you send CVS
and you sort of twitting thumbs in you
jump on a video and do that yeah we jump
so there's an in between between so when
we send TVs we're re we're getting a
much higher success rate between the
amount of people we send and the amount
of people that are invited to interview
because we're working with our client
and if they're saying no on someone we
say why we understand why so we're
trying to operate similar to how an
exact search firm would work you know
they get paid a kickoff they have
calibration profiles they then do first
round interviews we're trying to do that
but in a a shorter period of time and
the quality is way better because our
clients like okay they're listening and
if they're not listening at least
they're taking it on board so the
process is do the job briefing call Y
post that okay well what we're going to
do is we're going to have another call
in 48 hours and we're going to talk
through some of the uh initial people
that we've already spoken to we think
that that could be right and we want to
get some immediate feedback just to make
sure that you know we we've understood
and we've heard exactly what you're
looking for what you're not looking for
yeah um and then two days later you'll
then get you know the first round of um
CVS that we want you to consider y for
interview yeah and just ask when are you
fre in 48 hours time have you got that
you're good at doing that when are you
free what time works and it sounds silly
it's so small but God it helps so much
because um my team get frustrated when
they're not hearing back on their
candidates and it's every recruiter
feels it so getting that bind from your
client say look brilliant brief thanks
for giving us an hour we try and make
every briefing call an hour if we can 48
hours I need to speak to to again and
we're going to present people and they
go oh that's that's quick that's
exciting say yeah it is exciting but
we're going to need your honest feedback
and we're going to need you on the call
and once they've brought into that the
first R into they tend to see a higher
percentage of the people we then s yeah
and then anything else you've
implemented in that process you added
any other moments like that I think
that's a really smart one yeah I mean if
it's a more senior search have a weekly
update call have something in the diary
that's on a recurring event I've seen
I've heard this a lot about um how
recruiters work with their clients but
the more time you can have with their
client I think every time you speak with
your client um you're one step closer to
making a deal because even if that
person falls out they'll come back to
you because you've been so engaged and
and clients love it when you're engaged
and passionate about what you're doing
so the more touch points you can have
with your client um the better learn
their Rhythm what's the best time to
give you a call next week when are you
typically free when are you quiet
periods um learning your learning your
clients is is key and as by having that
approach enabled you um more easily to
ask for some Financial commitment
upfront definitely definitely
um yeah 100 100% because it's that it's
all comes down to trust but the 50% up
front is um why did the how do you
position that what's the frame like why
uh well I typically try and only do it
on people that we worked with before but
I say look once you after you work yeah
so on the second role that we work with
them I say look we're going to need 50%
up front here and the reasons why are XY
Z I'll say I want to invest more time in
this and I want to make it Priority um I
know we can place this role and I'm
committed to doing that so I'm going to
need some investment from you up front
it's no no problem in saying I'm really
busy at the moment but I want to
prioritize Your Role I'm going to need
some investment up front and I'm going
to allocate more of my team to it I'm
going to actually give you two resources
as part of the deal um instead of maybe
just you'll hear from us from CV so um
yeah there's obviously resistance and
people were like why am I paying what's
the normal objection
um well you get paid when you find
someone good and when we hire someone um
instead of just you know I'm going to
give you some money up front and what
what happens if you don't find us anyway
um that's what they normally say they
not say like d but we've just W this way
why why do we have to
change I think it comes down to
priorities we really want to prioritize
you and this is the way this is more of
a partnership it's very I think a lot of
recruiters they put clients on pedestals
right and they're scared of them and
they're like oh my God you know okay
whatever you say goes but actually it
has to be more of a partnership and I
think that's what the best recruiters
are doing at the moment they're treating
it as they're equals I'm a recruiter I'm
busy with my own clients but I I do
enjoy working with you in order for us
to have a really good relationship I'm
going to need some commitment up front
and when you phrase it like that people
see people see it see the value I try
and always have those conversations in
person if I can I always get pushed back
that's fine um but then I tell them
about the success stories about a few
clients that have done it recently and
how we've operated and the time to hire
shortens because you've got more people
on the search the client works better
with you we give better better
candidates your way um there's so many
advantages of of just getting a little
bit up front as I said even if it's
£1,000 you'd be surprised how good that
client then
becomes that's interesting love that so
how how are you thinking about how you
thinking about the next six six or month
six six or 12 months then
um I'm really excited I'm really really
excited because now we've got we've
placed 100 roles in
sport um I'm really excited for the team
to have gone past that journey of the
first sort 6 nine months in recruitment
and have that confidence that maybe I
had after my first deal where they get
on the phone or they're pitching to new
businesses and they are they're killing
it and I know and I know they've all got
the potential to do that it's really
really tough at the moment because it's
it's a tougher market for recruiters so
we're getting more push back but they're
all they're learning what a tough Market
is which I think is great um it's not
great when obviously I've got investors
and people that are reporting to that
are saying the revenue is down which is
tricky but if Consultants can understand
what a tough Market looks like when it
bounces back fully I think we're going
to be flying but my my focus in the next
six months is all around the US market
and how we can attack that how we can do
that really really well I'd like to go
over there more and meet with our
clients and cans and really understand
um the nitty-gritty of the challenges of
their business not just I've seen a r
advertized can I work it I I want to
know who you are I want to know your pay
points so that as again I know how to
sell back um yeah I'm passionate about
recruitment not being transactional and
I think that's why clients have bought
into me because they see that I'm trying
to do something good and there is value
in what we're trying to do and we're an
expert which is good yeah then honestly
I think like kudos to you on uh you know
early on here I'm sure you're like just
getting started yeah and uh I just I
think this is what's so cool about our
industry that you know when you do it
properly and you really commit to
solving these problems for companies you
can build a business out of nothing yeah
right which is which is what you're
doing like you didn't have a previous
Network all these things which a lot of
recruiters have when they start um and
you're building something which is in in
an area that you're really passionate
about and you've just been really
committed to understanding the world
understanding the problems that you can
solve and then you just continued to
improve it over time so I'm really
excited to see you know where you guys
are in another six to 12 months but also
yeah like commend you for like building
everything to now think that's awesome
because I'm sure you know early on like
you were saying you're like what the
[__] have I done um but you you kept
pushing through yeah um and now here and
like you said probably just just getting
started which you are but you you've
built something out of out of nothing
really which I really commend and I
think is is just super cool about our
industry yeah definitely if it was easy
everyone would I really believe in that
so thanks for coming on the Pod mate no
problem thanks for having me on